is there any greater computer on planet
earth than the human brain that web of
almost 200 billion neurons inside your
skull gives you the equivalent memory
space of over a thousand one terabyte
hard drives sure the human brain might
not be able to process information at
the speed of the average computer but it
can regulate the movement and functions
of your entire body all while using less
energy than a light bulb that's right
our brains are pretty impressive organic
computers but there is some stiff
competition well not completely stiff
you'll see say hello to scp-003
also referred to as the biological
motherboard hearing that name you would
be right to assume that scp-003
is a computer formed of organic
components as opposed to man-made
microchips and circuit boards but there
is a little bit more to it than that
scp-003 is actually composed of two
distinct parts referred to as scp-003-1
and
scp-003-2 both related but each with a
separate origin the former 003-1
is the machine's motherboard whereas
your ordinary home computer or laptop
might have a motherboard made out of
fiberglass and copper this one is far
less conventional so what is 003-1
actually made from the answer is living
tissue everything from hair and
fingernails to chitin which is a
substance found in the exoskeletons of
some invertebrate animals all of these
components parts that may have once
belonged to a living thing are arranged
in a configuration much like that of a
computer's motherboard it sounds like
something plucked out of a film by john
carpenter or david cronenberg doesn't it
but how or why would someone ever
construct something like this well the
answer to that isn't clear so far the
only answers we have come from the scp
foundation's extensive testing of the
biological motherboard according to
researchers
scp-003-1 predates even the very
earliest modern circuits by several
thousands of years meaning that whoever
built it was certainly ahead of their
time also the motherboard is alive wait
did we forget to mention that
scp-003-1 has displayed at least a low
level of sentience during testing by the
foundation not enough to be considered
an active threat unless certain
conditions make it dangerous the second
component of
scp-003 is 003-2
a stone tablet that 003-1 was attached
to when it was first discovered the
surface of 003-2 has a number of runes
carved into it but these symbols don't
match letters or characters from any
known language the runes on 003-2 are
also known to regularly emit a pale
flickering pattern of light now you're
probably asking how is a slab of stone
able to light itself up well that is
because
scp-003-2 has an internal computer
controlling it and not one composed of
organic parts like hair and fingernails
somewhere within the stone is a
non-biological computer fueled by some
unknown anomalous power source the
foundation's researchers can't access
the internal components of
scp-003-2 without running the high risk
of damaging it but as far as they can
tell whatever is running this bizarre
machine has been slowly losing power for
centuries the biological motherboard is
also known to emit measurable levels of
heat light and radiations of an
anomalous nature so why would someone go
to the trouble of creating a computer
out of living parts and anomalous stone
and what is the purpose of the
biological motherboard the scp
foundation considers it highly probable
that the stone slab of 003-2 was
actually created with the intention of
keeping the motherboard component
003-1 contained additionally during
testing foundation researchers have been
able to exact partially complete data
from scp-003
this data seems to refer to some sort of
potential catastrophe either in the
future or one that has already occurred
as a direct result of scp-003-1
it would seem that
003-1 and 003-2 must stay combined in
order to prevent what the foundation
would deem an lk class restructuring
event how could the biological
motherboard cause an event like this it
just sounds like a partially alive flesh
circuit on a stone slab it's when the
temperature around scp-003 drops below
35 degrees celsius that things start to
get really strange from the minute they
detect a decrease in temperature both
components of scp-003 begin to react the
biological motherboard itself starts to
grow rapidly increasing its overall size
003-1 fuels this growth state by
absorbing any nearby matter adding
anything close enough to its fleshing
mass first it will assimilate any
inorganic material everything from
particles in the atmosphere on up
003-1 transforms these new additions to
itself into the same organic matter that
makes up the biological motherboard
transforming metal or plastic into dead
skin cells hair chitin enamel keratin
and other similar materials this growth
state increases until
scp-003 takes on a form in the shape of
an opheride also known as a brittle star
an aquatic life form similar to a
starfish with five long thin appendages
protruding from a central body in the
case of
scp-003 this body appears to be the
computer's central processing unit in
this new form the biological motherboard
will also begin to create sensory organs
that will survey the area around it for
more materials to assimilate only
003-2 the stone slab is immune to being
converted into biological matter next
the second phase of transformation
occurs and
scp-003-1 begins to absorb organic
matter into its mass as well
living or otherwise if you've ever seen
the blob then you know what this looks
like and how horrifying it would be for
any person unfortunate enough to be
standing too close
during this stage
scp-003 will attempt to copy the biology
of a living organism it comes into
contact with and uses this template to
try and lure others towards it however
the biological motherboard appears to
use a lot of processing power to analyze
and assimilate organic matter and this
can actually diminish the speed at which
it increases in size so what happens to
003-2 the stone component of scp-003
during all of this when the biological
motherboard is growing in changing form
melding with other organisms as its
fleshy mass increases does 003-2 power
its transformation no
in fact it tries to prevent it that's
right the two components of
scp-003 do not work in tandem they work
against each other as the biological
motherboard starts to grow the stone
slab attached to it will emit
concentrated bursts of radiation these
radioactive emissions have a counter
effect on
003-1's ability to assimilate matter and
increase its size stopping the organic
mass of flesh from growing and even
reversing the process when the
temperature is raised to over 100
degrees celsius what we have so far is a
machine in two parts one that grows and
assimilates matter at lower temperatures
and the other that releases radiation to
stop this happening naturally the scp
foundation counteracts the anomalous
growing ability of 003-1 by keeping the
biological motherboard in a heated
containment environment still attached
to 003-2
under no circumstances is the
temperature of
scp-003's containment unit to drop below
35 degrees celsius and normally no
living person is permitted to make any
direct contact with the machine however
in the event of an emergency resulting
in a loss of power foundation staff are
required to huddle skin to skin with the
fleshing mass of the motherboard in an
attempt to keep it warm through their
own body heat much like how penguins
huddle together for warmth of course
those unlucky members of personnel
probably hope they can generate enough
heat between them to keep 003-1 from
starting to grow otherwise they'll know
they'll be the first that the biological
motherboard will absorb should a member
of personnel be chosen for this
particularly unpleasant task of being on
hand to keep zero zero three warm then
they will be made to submit for a full
examination beforehand no one can be
allowed close to scp-003 if they're
carrying any bodily parasites like
tapeworms or head lice they would all be
extra organisms for 003-1 to absorb
foundation staff are also required to be
decontaminated both before and after
directly dealing with scp-003
and of course no member of the scp
foundation is permitted to ever detach
the biological motherboard from the
stone component given that 003-2 is the
only device capable of reducing and
reversing
scp-003-1's growth
any changes in the pattern or color of
its glowing ruins is to be reported to
high-ranking members of the foundation
there have been multiple incidents
involving scp-003 though usually
occurring when staff working in the
foundation's m03 gloria research team
attempt to push the boundaries of the
device's anomalous properties their
interest in the biological motherboard
lies purely in seeing how the machine
evolves when allowed to grow beyond its
second brittle star stage during one
such incident
003-1 was allowed to grow and
restructure for just over 9 minutes
after which the containment area's
temperature was lowered and 003-2
released a massive continuous spike in
radiation any of the new material that
had been bonded to the biological
motherboard dissolved falling away and
turning into a dusty residue which was
then collected for testing at this point
both 003-1 and 003-2 seemed to power
down with no detectable activity the
stone slab did not power back on until
it was connected to an external power
generator when the same procedure was
repeated and 003-1 re-entered its growth
state
003-2's radiation appeared to be unable
to stop the motherboard from increasing
in mass when it reached 4 times its
original size by assimilating any and
all matter it could reach
scp-003 then began to change form in a
way that had never been observed before
forming a protective shell around 003-1
the entire living machine breached
containment into the observation area
grabbing m03 gloria researchers and its
appendages using these m03 gloria
members it began adding to itself and
forming a new body as it assimilated the
researchers the biological motherboard
rearranged its center mass
scp-003 then took on the form of a three
meter tall female humanoid with
tentacles protruding from its newly
formed hair and spine next the part
creature part machine began to make
indecipherable sounds trying to
communicate with researchers through
these rudimentary vocalizations
somehow perhaps through information and
that absorbed from the researchers in
its grasp
scp-003 wanted to speak what happened
next an agent sent on orders direct from
the o5 council was dispatched to the
containment area according to foundation
records the agent attempted to engage in
conversation with
scp-003's new form but any data about
their exchange has been expunged luckily
this agent was able to restore power to
scp-003 stone component returning the
room temperature to the proper
containment levels which caused 003-1 to
return to its normal state the threat
recontained all nine members of m03
gloria were found to be unharmed
suffering no side effects from
assimilation other than a few cases of
psychological trauma one of them dr
tilda moose the leader of m03 gloria was
later interviewed by the foundation she
claimed that
scp-003 had tried to talk to the
researchers connecting with them
mentally in a crude broken language that
they couldn't understand she ripped
three of the researchers apart and put
them back together unharmed she doesn't
understand human emotion or pain or very
much about how we experience the world
yes i would say the containment
procedures are necessary according to dr
moose scp-003
is some unknown alien entity one without
a clear understanding of humanity it
cannot understand pain or physical
sensation yet it is bent on remaking the
world into a paradise the whole effect
felt like words of some kind i believe
she wanted to see what we could
understand so she could understand us dr
moose said in her interview she didn't
have time to finish analyzing us i don't
know what would have happened if she had
now check out
scp-001 the broken god or boro cycle and
scp-1461 house of the worm for more
tales of anomalous machines with minds
of their own